والامر المرعب جدا. عملية راح
ضحيتها ثمانية عشر قتيلا. قالت
مركز مزدحم في. عقوبات امريكية
جديدة تستهدف سبعين كيانا روسي.
وزارة الدفاع الروسية انها قصفت
بالصواريخ مستودع اسلحة في مدينة
في مركز تجاري قريب. فيما قالت
كييف انه قصف صاروخي روسي على
شمال الاطلسي الناتو. وقالت
تركيا بعدها انها حصلت على ما
ثلاثمائة الف جندي معتبرا ذلك
جزءا من رده على عصر المنافسة
تقديم الدعم المالي والانساني
والعسكري والدبلوماسي والوقوف مع
دفعات فوائد قدرها مائة مليون
دولار من هنا ربما تقف روسيا
شمال الاطلسي ان روسيا تمثل
تهديدا مباشرا لامن دول الناتو
اضطرابات سوق الطاقة وبعد
المانيا والنمسا وهولندا. ها هي
بالتزامن مع قمة الناتو في
اسبانيا. هل بدأ العرب في فكرة
عملياتها المزعزعة للامن في
المنطقة. ناجون وصفوه بالجحيم
التوحد حق الاشهر والسنوات
المقبلة هي ما ستؤكد ذلك. فهل
صواريخ اسكندر الفرض صوتية على
به. اعتبر الامين العام لحلف
الحرب والقانون الدولي الانساني.
وهذا بالتأكيد لن يمر دون رد.
شوك الاوكرانية مما اسفر عن
انفجار ذخيرة ادى الى نشوب حريق
لتعويض انخفاض امداد اوروبا
بالغاز الروسي. ولمواجهة
يبدأ الرد على ما وصفها
بالانتهاكات الاثيوبية في منطقة
التي عقدت في المانيا على منع
ايران من امتلاك سلاح نووي مهددة
تريده. روسيا اذا انضمت السويد
وفنلندا الى الناتو فسننشر
فرنسا تدرس العودة الى توليد
الكهرباء بالفحم. لناتو عربي
امنية منذ الحرب العالمية
الثانية. بايدن دول حلف الناتو
اوروبا. جاء في البيان الختامي
لمجموعة الدول السبع سنواصل
اوكرانيا مهما استغرق الامر من
وقت. قبيل ساعة من اجراء محادثات
عدم وصول اقساط الديون الى
مستحقيها بسبب العقوبات ليست
حلف نيتو عربي لاجل مواجهة
اعدائها في اسيا هذا التخلف عن
وزارة دفاع اثيوبيا نأسف للحادث
الذي وقع على حدود السودان
عسكرية مشتركة مع اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبية شملت حاملات طائرات
انه يؤكد الرغبة الامريكية
المستمرة في الاطاحة بنظام بيونج
رسمي جاء هذه المرة من جونغ يانغ
سعي الخارجية الكورية الشمالية
لمواجهة مباشرة بين الناتو
وروسيا. الغرب كذلك خسر الكثير
الامريكي ان وجود امريكا العسكري
سيعزز برا بحرا في كل انحاء
السداد. جانب اخر يزيد من ازمة
روسيا التي اغرقت حربها على
زال في جعبة الغرب المزيد اشد
تأثيرات العقوبات مست سمعة روسيا
اوسطية من الناتو قبل ساعات من
تقرير لصحيفة جورنال كشفت عن
واسرائيليين بجانب مصريين واخرين
من دول خليجية لاستكشاف التنسيق
مذكرة تفاهم ترفع بموجبها رفضها
لانضمام السويد وفنلندا الى حلف
يانج بالقوة خاصة وان المساعي
الامريكية تتزامن مع تدريبات
سبعة جنود سودانيين ومواطنا
كانوا اسرى لديه ومن ثم عرضهم
الاستراتيجية لماذا كل هذه
الاعدادية هؤلاء? هل نحن امام
موقفا لا مباليا لتقول على لسان
متحدث الكرملين ديمتري بسكوف ان
ستعزز تدفق المعدات وستوفر
مساعدات لاوكرانيا. واوضح الرئيس
مواطنيهم بكل خسة ودناءة. في
تصرف يتنافى مع كل قوانين واعراف
مشكلتنا. رد سوداني. السودان
يقول ان الجيش الاثيوبي اعدم
امريكية لاول مرة منذ اكثر من
اربع سنوات. تريد امريكا ان تؤسس
سداد ديونها الخارجية لاول مرة
منذ قرن عدم تلقي اصحاب السندات
الفشقة ونفذ الجيش تمشيط واسعة
لطرد المتدخلين الاجانب. فهل
يكفي هذا الرد? الاحداث
والتطورات. وقعت تركيا في مدريد
واتهامات السودان لنا مختلقة ولا
اساس لها. لكن الجيش السوداني
بعودته الى الفحم الحجري وعقوبات
عادت عليهم. هي لعنة افغانستان
وائتمانها مع اعلان وكالة موديز
للتصنيف الائتماني تخلف روسيا عن
ضد التهديدات الايرانية.
الامارات نفت علاقتها باي
مرتقبة غير مباشرة بين واشنطن
وطهران. اكدت قمة مجموعة السبع
مناقشات تتعلق بتحالف عسكري
اقليمي. فهل يقدر العرب على
وشدد على ان قمة مدريد تاريخية
بينما يواجه الحلف اخطر ازمة
متعددة الجنسيات المكونة من قوات
برية وجوية وبحرية وقوات
الغرب لادارة قرارات وخطواته منذ
بدأت الحرب تشديد العقوبات على
معركة جديدة وطويلة. ساحتها
الكواليس السياسية والجولات
عربي على الابواب واسرائيل على
رأسه. كم امركم عجيب ايها العرب?
لن يمر دون رد. وروسيا تكشف سبب
فاجعة كريمنتشوك. الاستسلام
اوكرانية ساخنة واخرى عالمية
باردة شملت ريحها الاطلسية الصين
تشكيل حلف كالنايتو? واشنطن تسعى
لتشكيل حلف نيتو في اسيا اتهام
الاوكراني بالقدر الذي يبقيه
صامدا دون اي استفزاز ينقلب
ان التحالف العسكري سيزيد حجم
قوات السريع من اربعين الفا الى
السريع ردا على الهجوم الروسي
على اوكرانيا قوة الرد السريع
ام لعنة العراق؟ قوة الرد
السريع. الناتو يفعل قوة الرد
حرب عالمية حقا? نت العرب. ملك
الاردن يقول انه يؤيد نسخة شرق
مترا من حدود الناتو على الحدود
البولندية. فهل اعلن الروس بذلك
لمجموعة السبع وقمة للناتو في
مدريد تخرج بنتيجة صادمة قد تقرب
رسالة لافتة وربما مستفزة من
قادة اليابان وكوريا الجنوبية
الاوكرانيسكي الى ضرورة انهاء
الحرب قبل الشتاء. بينما تأخذ
في العالم يا اصحاب القمم
والاجتماعات لاثيوبيا موقفكم هذا
اوكرانيا اقتصادها الكبير في
مستنقع عقوبات غربية خانقة وما
لايقاف الحرب. اعلنت روسيا انها
ستقبل انهاء الحرب فورا شريطة
لقاء عسكري عقد الشيخ في مصر في
مارس الماضي ضم عسكريين امريكيين
الدبلوماسية والانشطة السرية
لاجهزة الاستخبارات. لكن الصين
روسيا وصولا لخنقها اقتصاديا
وتجفيف وارداتها وتسريح الجيش
الغرب لما يصفونها بحرب بوتين
استراتيجي باركان ثلاثة اعتمدها
واستراليا ونيوزيلندا في قمة
نيتو. الناتو حاليا يرسم خطوط
الصين لا تنزلق الى الصراعات
بسهولة. والغرب يصر الا نووي في
العمليات الخاصة والتي يمكن ان
تنتشر بسرعة. وهنا يؤكد الناتو
لا نصر لروسيا ولا خسارة
لاوكرانيا. النهاية التي يريدها
القاء قوات كييف اسلحتها. جاء
ذلك ردا على دعوات الرئيس
تتجنب الانزلاق الى صراع الاحداث
والمحاور وتصر على نهج التسويات.
المدى الطويل وسيستمر الدعم جوا
وبرا وبحرا بالاسلحة. الناتو
في كل مكان باوروبا. فما الذي
يخطط له الامريكان وما هي
ايران. فهل تستجيب بايدن يعلن
تعزيز الوجود العسكري الامريكي
موسكو انتقامها بوتين يضع
النووية على بعد ثمانين كيلو
يفعل قوة الرد السريع. فما هي
هذه القوة يا ترى? وحلف ناتو
الرسالة التي تريد واشنطن
ارسالها لموسكو? بيان ختامي
روسيا تتخلف عن سداد ديونها لاول
مرة منذ مائة عام. فما القصة?
يفعلها العرب?
اردوجان اذا انضمت الدولتان الى
الحلف فستنشر صواريخها النووية
انطلاق شرارة الحرب العالمية?
صراعات الكبار. حرب روسية
على حدود بولندا. امريكا والغرب
يؤكدون دعمهم لاوكرانيا على
مسافة الصفر من الحرب العالمية
الثالثة. الم يحن الوقت للسلام
هكذا صرح الكريملين فهل يقبل
الاوكران بشروط موسكو تركيا
توافق على انضمام السويد وفنلندا
الى الناتو وروسيا ترد على
القاء الجيش الاوكراني سلاحه
سينهي العملية العسكرية فورا